so blacken is I'm call it a fable of
them of power and it's um attracts a
president of an unnamed country is
deposed and his chef and father and
portraitist imprisoned after the coup
and are forced to sort of account for
what they've done and how they've
inadvertently popped up his regime even
though they worked for him in a kind of
non-political capacity and they still am
just by sort of nourishing here more
rendering his his portrait or by
grooming him have had lent him a kind of
legitimacy and in their significant
women in their lives speak in turn and
damen to sort of signal that the kind of
moral and psychological fallout in a
political situation where is a corrupt
leader and and how that's sort of
trickled down to the general population
I think I wanted to get at this issue of
women not simply being victims so I
started out with the male voices and
then realized that they needed a counter
balancing force where and you know these
women are not sitting in the shadows
waiting for them in there just as
implicated in in many of the cycles of
abuse that are set in motion where today
personal or political and and so and
it's meant to kind of show I guess the
the pain and the hurt that's inflicted
by the men that that has also been
enjoyed by them at the hands of the
woman so
you